來吧 我們聊聊怎麼拍短日頻 我的一整套系統
注意 我說的是我拍短日頻的一整套系統
而不是說拍短日頻的一件事 比如說沒有0感
怎麼辦 因為很人拍拍沒0感
對吧 拍不下去了
然後呢 怎麼去擊類資產
我一直說三年就是一輩子
我幾乎每年就會完成一次生情
然後的資產在不斷的不斷的消失
這個東西到底是怎麼做的
那麼下一步的話到底是怎麼做
所以距離在怎麼拍 該怎麼做 每個細節是什麼
今天我們開玩意不回應
這個就是算是框架型的一個總結吧
然後想了 首先我們說第一件事情
這是沒0感怎麼辦
我們拍短日頻有一個大格
通常人才用的方法是什麼呢
就是我今天要拍什麼 我先想我的拍什麼
第二不就是我想的我們拍
然後開始拍
拍拍拍去的 發現這段有問題
然後你要從英拍攝
就這個的角色成本是非常好的
那我個人怎麼辦呢
它其實我是分開的
就是決策和執情是分開的
為什麼
因為我要拍什麼
這是發散 老的是發散系統 發散的
拍是具有 要保持專注
然後你就會發現你也太太太的
那時候一邊發散 一邊受臉
一邊發散 一邊受臉
這現在開始誒 一腳踩的用門 一腳踩
一腳踩 一腳踩 一腳踩 一腳踩
這個很辛苦的
所以方法是什麼呢
各位把你的發散系統
就天嘛 它心痛的那個
那個放開 和你真正開始
專注的這個事情
兩邊放開
那我這怎麼做呢
就是我呢就會用複模
我個人複模
這不是推薦工具啊
我是這是比較好用
我個人的話就是有時候有些什麼樣的想法
我就會隨時把它
把它記起來
就是可能於句話 兩句話
三次句話 把它記起來
靈感 動階 想法
但我不用專門處理它
它就是一個靈感一個想法的動階
我看出的時候
我做事的時候
我反思總結的時候
把它記起來 這就是靈感
只要有靈感 你放你
只要有靈感 你放你去
但是放你的時候
我並不招提處理
我只是把靈感動階放在這裡
然後的話呢
我每天的時候
你看我每天的時候
不可以啊
就是我就可以這樣做
像他呢
他就有一個美日回顧
美日回顧就是把以前的動階拿出來看
以前的一些靈感
可能是三年前的可能是五天前的
可能是一周田的 對吧
你就把它拿出來
拿出來的話呢
就是在照
你就看靈感 這個靈感 喝過事
這個靈感 喝過事
你看到一個靈感
你就覺得這個靈感可能可行
照 你找到這個靈感的時候
你覺得這個靈感可行的時候
因為你之前是有期待的嘛 對吧
你看啊 比如說這個靈感可行啊
注意啊
我就可以找到之前
所有和這個靈感相關的指示
這個時候我開始進入創作
所以呢
我個人是把靈感發散
就是平時的碎片記錄了
然後用的時候
就是找到一個靈感
然後看選擇那個靈感
或是就開始
就開始做
就是專注的播出生態的
這是第一個部分
解決靈感庫的問題
和解鎖的問題這是分開的
第二件事情的話
我說資產這個事
這個是我們很多人
可能沒有注意到的事情
就是我們很多人
掉到的拍短視頻的
包括那邊
然後各種交路語
今天有留亮了
明天有留亮了
對吧
我給大家講過是怎麼想的啊
其實我之前也交流
拍短視頻有的時候
一拍好幾百萬的播放量
突然間
那天只有幾十萬的播放量
你就很上火
對吧
但現在的話
其實我完全的想明白了
怎麼想明白的
我說幾個事
第一個事是什麼呢
就是我發現了一個問題
就是我
你要知道短視頻啊
你如果要不放量
高
他已經是面向更多的人群
然後就發現了一個問題
就是我拍東西服裕表面
如果你講聲
就沒有用過了
其實沒有用過了
因為說個難聽哪的話
我們有90%的人沒做過飛機
90%的人沒做過飛機
然後呢
很多人在收入
其實沒有那麼高的
然後你如果講的東西
特別深的話
那麼別人是看不懂的
然後呢
我這樣在視頻就是這樣
然後你要想有大的力量
你必須通鎖一動
把一個東西通鎖一動
但是有些東西
真的沒有辦法講的通鎖一動
因為他就是需要深入的
反正只要我的能力不夠
因為照成什麼動物呢
我講的東西總是服裕表面
然後呢
我個人
你講的東西
服裕表面
他你的世界只有見的
你自己就服裕表面
這是我說的第一件事情
這是我之前發現的一個問題
然後第二個問題
就是當你去拍攝的時候
就是你的那個流量的問題
因為有一個東西叫資產
就是如果你是關注流量的話
你注意到有流量
你就需要連關注兩個東西
一個東西什麼呢
一個東西是平台的算法
對吧
因為平台有流量一定是
我願意能夠服裕平台的算法
有沒有流量取於算法的
第二個部分是
用呼 用呼吸不起吧
用呼吸法的點贊助上
這東西回到算法裡的
對不對
所以你要想有流量管中量的
平台算法一個是
一個是用呼
是不是喜歡用呼的這個呼動
但是當我們把關注點放到這的時候
我又回到那個點了
就是你要去考慮算法
考慮什麼東西
最後拍個流量出來可能
三天之後一周以後就過期了
但是我希望的是什麼呢
就是
我就是我之前一來講
一次學習中身手用
這裡沒有兩塊
第一個是我學東西
一定是學好東西
學了這個支持中身手用
第二個是我
喜歡這個東西之後
我做出這個東西中身手用
我不希望我拍的東西
三天以後過期的五天以後過期了
我希望這個支持
它一直有用的
那我發現之前那個方法也做不到
然後第三個部分我給大家講
叫控制而分吧
什麼意思呢
就是
一個是平報報
其實不取於你
它是有一定的概率的
雖然你可以提升那個概率
剛才我說了嘛
對吧
原因是什麼
一個是算法
一個是用戶的互動嘛
對吧
那麼
它是有一定的概率的
如果你關注那個
你會很焦慮
那我個人來說的話
更關注一次餐
我認為好的東西一定是用戶的
受到用戶的反覆的
哪怕就用戶人少
但這個需求也會很好
對吧
深度那種主意講的
特別的背好
難得就是說講不說特別的背好
它也應該會有流量
所以這個時候我就會去想
我不要把關注點放在
我不能控制事情上
我要把關注點放在我不能控制事情上
我要把關注點放在我能控制事情上
我能控制事情上什麼
而且我從前面那個地方來說
我認為我的支持一定要我深度
一定要我深度
那麼這時候就要損失
短期的利益
我要有深度
第二個這個支持是不斷解答的
這三個東西它有一個很好的角度
所以最後我決定我拍短日
不再關注算法
不再關注流量
不再關注 包括
我就關注內容的深度
好的角度
這個支持不斷疊待可以做一哭存的
我是採用的這樣的一個方法
但這樣做的話好
這確點是什麼呢
就是你會發現短期內
就真的沒有流量了
你會發現
也我確實我現在我的短期
沒有流量了
但是我仍然這麼去做
為什麼
你會發現另外一個數據
就是我的流量疊了
但是你會發現
我幾乎每個月都是
會有8萬多十萬的法師中長
所以你想想
就是你的用不更其中了
你的用不更
你突開的面而沒那麼大
但是用不更其中了
我跟九個小的一子就好了
就是比如說我開了個電
然後我對外圈什麼
以前那時候一百萬人
每次圈圈有一百萬人看到
現在只有十萬人看到了
但是呢
以前是一百萬人看到
來你電的可能只有四萬人
但是呢
你會發現你現在只有十萬人看到
但你來你電影的人有七二人
你會覺得哪個更何事呢
對吧
這是我說的第二個部分
我想跟那樣分享的是
我現在我要關的是創造資產
一直有用的資產
三年五年十年
看看有什麼資產
而不是三天
一個禮拜也會估期的消費品
就是我講了
思想
那麼我再跟大家分享
到底怎麼做
有了這個東西以後
我到底該怎麼做
那我跟大家去一下例子
我的工作時間是三十分鐘
我給自己一個三十分鐘的時間
拍攝的那邊也是三十分鐘的時間
我以前就是十分鐘
現在我給自己三十分鐘
怎麼做呢
就是我每天
給大家分享了
就是我幹嘛那每天
就是會打開每日回顧
看看我的靈感護理人
有哪些東西可以講
它就半天沒出來
對吧
靈感護理沒有那些東西
可以講了
我可以分享翻
對吧
我可以看
有那些我去選擇
和其中一個靈感護
這個時候注意到了
我不是去
限決定到底要拍什麼
而是一開始就在這個裡面
花個兩三分鐘
三五分鐘
決定我要拍什麼
我要拍什麼
然後決定了以後
我可以看相關的
過去的相關的內容
然後再對一些
直視之間
接著連連連接
這個限力連接的時候
我就可能會有新的東西
因為
你可以三個月之前
一個相關的直視
兩周前一個相關的直視
這些東西都是相關的直視
這些直視連在一塊
它就會產生了
你也什麼是創新
什麼是直視
就是在兩個看你的
毫無相關的
事務之間
先了一點點
直視就會產生新的東西
那麼這個時候的話
我就可以查看
查閱相關的書記
或者通過AI
我去更深入的了解
然後再產生新的東西
注意這個時候
我需要我花二十分鐘的時間
去思考這個東西
我花二十分鐘
走落三十分鐘
我花二十分鐘去思考這個東西
為什麼
因為我認為
深度的思考公主要
一個東西
它是有深度的
它這個思想很棒
但是表達形式不好
不要緊
這個直視
它時間的考驗是可以的
但是如果這個東西沒有用
表面在光滑
很快就會過去
所以我會花
更多的時間去思考
然後二十分鐘完了以後
我留五到十分鐘
去拍攝
注意啊
這個時候和別人拍攝又不太一樣了
你如果早期
你可以把我這個方法改變
但是我就是好了
我以為我深度的思想
這個時候
我不寫任何文案
我是直接拍攝的
為什麼呢
因為以前的時候會有一點點
會被他寫
後來我發現
有了AI之後用語音很好
因為說皮寫快
快速說
思想是流場的
關鍵點不會丟失的
然後讓AI幫我生成
這樣它的速度會很快
但是我後來想
我既然拍完視頻
我就直接拍了算了
然後我就直接拍
不再說了
拍完短
就想到有這麼一個領導
我就直接拍了
你們可以看我拍攝的事情這樣
可能覺得我多做
那這個因為
我從來沒有準備
就是想要就這麼說
說完以後
然後讓AI提取
文案
提取文案
提取文案以後
然後讓他
根據這個文案
回徒產生BD
產生BD以後
然後我再開始進去
注意這個時候
我的支持
在我這經過了三次
第一個部分就是
我深度思考了之後
然後我開始拍攝
把我之前的支持宣傳連接
就是因此
第二次的話
AI出來的時候
然後我好好地把它
就整理一下
讓AI在重新把我繪圖
幫我重新繪圖
結構圖拿出來
這是兩次
第三次的話
我在檢擊的時候
我會把我的那個圖
一個個的配到相關的那種
裡面就是三次
一個那種三次
然後重新生成一個
支持
只是卡片
回到
我以前的那個靈安庫里面
注意到回到
這些什麼意思呢
就是我這次的那個
版本是1.0
可能兩個月以後
又刷到到這個那種
每日回復後
它是隨機的嗎
可能又刷到的那種
我在做的時候
就機率前的那個靈安庫了做了
所以這次可能是2.0
在過一段時間
可能是3.0
我這次沒拍好
不要緊
它可能就讓我
不高不要緊
就讓我說
沒本質地打點清楚
但是你反而兩個月之後
2.0
3.1月以後
可能3.0
4.0
5.0
我對這個支持的
理解
它的深度
是完全不一樣
所以
我想跟大家分享一個觀點
這是當時忙碶
說過一個概念
就是你不需要知道那麼多支持
一個人
它能學有所用的
一個很重要的原因是什麼
找到什麼支持是
有用的
反腐調擁它
不斷地假設那些反腐調的
什麼東西
支持是沒用的
把它徵完的
對吧
所以一個了你看
就是真正的支持
你只要把它用出來
其實你不需要那麼多支持
對它反而你知道很多支持
用不來
是沒用的
所以我這個
你本來有一個反腐調的過程
就是
生成反腐
在任務為我的支持庫里
過上一本很有把他抽出來了
2.0
3.0
然後呢
這裡有個點是什麼呢
就是我不指望我的所有的支持
滿足所有的人了
我是在滿足
昨天的資集
我不知道大家能不能理解
我在我的用戶範圍少了
我也不需要管中那麼多範圍
因為我就
關注昨天的資集
那就很有意思
總有一些人和我是一樣的
那我只需要做一件事情
我根本不需要關注
別人喜不喜歡這個那種
我就去努力
去生長就好了
然後只要
只要我的這個那種
是滿足昨天的資集的
那麼就會很多
和我昨天我是一樣的
所以這個的那種
對他們也有幫助
你們這些那種就會
不斷地變成資產
而不是兩三天
國企的東西
所以好好思考一下
各位
第一個本來能不能把你的
創意的過程的靈感哭
和你真正做瘦的那個那種
把它分開
靈感是
碎片而閃閃靈感
專注生長的那種
那麼第二個部分的話
你在拍攝的時候
大家你可以改變一下
我個人是這樣的
就會找到我的靈感
三十分鐘找到我的靈感
然後二十分鐘專注
知識的靈感
然後專注的去
去產生想法
去深入一個知識
二十分鐘創造資產
十分鐘表達
這個時候我的關注點是什麼
我的關注點是
那個冬天
在你們那拍攝短這邊是中間
在我這拍攝短這邊是
是七點
最終我會有一種
不斷升級
更新的冬天
就是有很多很多的資產
第三個的話
我覺得看出去重要的一點
各位
就是你應該用系統
去完成拍攝短的靈感哭事情
然後讓你不斷地產生
一個又一個
甚至昨天對你非常有用的
不斷掉入了
對你人生幫助特別大的
冬天和資產
而不是拍了一個
發了一個研發
兩三天過期的消費品